jeffrey congratulations a very good
start for you especially that game that
victory against fabiano
you were blitzing out through the
opening moves how much did you know
yeah i think i
i definitely knew this idea with um
with knight d4 and rook d1
and i think i remember it's still fine
for him
but he has to find
uh it's a very difficult move yeah
it does work yeah bishop h3 and so you
knew about this move you've analyzed it
well i know that the engine still showed
its equal um i didn't delve into the
lines but
but yeah this makes sense and i guess
besides bishop h3 maybe
i mean uh instead of a stage three for
black he doesn't have another way to
equalize no no knight to c6 but
allowing this is not very happy yeah
when i can get the two bishops open you
know it should be quite pleasant and
after that there was another critical
moment all the way until the end
you played this move not even here all
the way i think it was
let's keep going
bishop to c3 yes you got your pawn all
the way to h6
bishop to c2 king to g7 and now rook to
d3 ah yeah yeah i i definitely wonder
this idea would you spot this move no no
um i didn't see his id in the game
either
yeah he he did mention this to me and
it was yeah kind of uh f7 doesn't work
because of rook to d7 h7 the same
and after a bishop to b2 just check you
go to h8 check or bishop to d3 and if
you do go uh rook to g8 just simply look
to d7
while stuff in this one he did not find
it big victory uh for you against
fabiano a customer you know so well
because you guys also had a huge battle
at the american cup how did that victory
feel for you
well yeah i mean i think
any win in this tournament is very nice
um
but yeah i guess the slight revenge from
that match
uh was a bonus
and then in the last one against
dominguez it felt like you're building
up quite a
serious advantage did you feel that way
as well
yeah i think
especially when he was getting really
low on time and i got an e4 i felt like
looked extremely promising for me but
somewhere i think maybe i got too fancy
with uh with bishop c1
and you had this
moment ago queen to d3 followed by e3
yeah i i didn't notice this i
oh i forgot okay i forgot i have a rook
f5 okay yeah it's just oh yeah this was
a was a big miss i guess and after
bishop to c1 he managed to find this
move rook to f7 which actually just
equalizes the game on the spot
jeffrey is still a very good result for
you how do you feel about your chances
in this tournament what is the goal for
this tournament
i wouldn't say that i'm thinking about
that i think it's still very early so
just trying to um to play as well as i
can and see what results i get
congratulations jeffrey we'll see you
tomorrow yeah we'll play jeffrey i
applied indeed absolutely and uh for
jeffrey is these uh wild card players
i'm waiting for him to become a